Hey mr. O'Brien yeah who are you hurry
the [ __ ] up
sorry it's me Nicholas Braun my show
succession it's I'm not shooting hiatus
right now so so I'm looking for a job
looking for a job you're looking for a
job yeah okay
yeah no wonder I call you Steve house
Steve is Steve a good name to call you
my name is Nicholas wait a minute did
you just come into my office and say I
couldn't call you Steve that was that no
what are you doing what are you doing I
was doing what you were doing you say I
can't call you Steve and then you start
making bubbles with your mouth guess
what I've been on the air 26 years
I interviewed Billy [ __ ] Crudup yeah
I think he's crewed up what no it's
William crewed up no one would be named
crewed up it would be caught up that's
the only name it could be what are you
crazy why don't you get the [ __ ] out of
my office
okay okay see you again but I have a
proposal oh really
yeah I want to be your sidekick strong
bold move from the Nick Meister I think
I like it Nicholas my sister yeah call
me the fall
yeah oh I hope so
actually have a great catchphrase
catchphrase for my show for you okay I
mean I hate to ask what's here it's
Conan went there you are raw clay and I
would like to mold you yeah mold me put
me in the oven get me real hard oh you
don't that's snow I want to show you my
TV Empire see the Empire time
what are you doing do I ever [ __ ]
high-five me alright you're trying high
five me again I'll shove a grenade in
your penis do you understand oh my god
Nicholas um I'm such a huge fan of yours
on succession do you mind if I take a
selfie really quick oh I have a great
idea why don't you get a selfie with
your pink slip cuz you're [ __ ] fired
take a walk har burn your card and then
take the bus and go home you're out
you've done get out
here so I'm so sorry chew it got Diane
fired what you just did that
Conan you just fired her I like that
plausible deniability
you are a Cobra Nicholas must be packin
some brass balls down yeah all right
that's me the brass ball man yeah look
you want a job here yeah I need cocaine
cocaine why do you no no listen what you
think I need cocaine for a sketch on the
show sketch oh well you can just use
flour wow that's a great idea
Little Debbie I'm gonna write it away
pink jewelry what a great I didn't know
I want real cocaine it's got to be from
Peru get it [ __ ] get me the cocaine
okay all right I'm your Little Debbie
Baker's doesn't hey Nick you trying to
take my sidekick job oh you're gonna be
so great at it go to hell so deserve it
don't you know mr. Richter I'm not
trying to have with you Conan wants to
give me that job because we have this
like instant and undeniable chemistry
that's just sort of firing off all
cylinders right now then I can't help
that
oh so you just waltz in here after I've
been the sidekick for 10 years and I'm
like some kind of coffee table made out
of [ __ ] that you can put your feet up on
no you are you are so much more than a
coffee table made of [ __ ] you're so much
more structurally sound hey red pill
Ryan Stiles where's my coke okay it's
been like three minutes where is I know
I'm about to call my I'm about to call
your guy who's your guy beggar bagger
bag or what Bagger Vance he's alleged
get us the cocaine then have for two
sketches
[Music]
I'm gonna get the best [ __ ] coke I
always say conan went there sir oh yeah
yep yep no weapons good to go all right
yeah raise your arms please thank you
yeah I can't raise them I know a
shoulder thing so I can't raise no no no
that's just you can't bring illicit
drugs into the stereo color please no no
I should put that on my ass please sir
Conan Conan yes oh good can you tell him
about the never seen him before in my
life
wait a minute hold on yes I yes yes the
sexual offender registry yeah know what
why are you reading the sex offender
registry I'm an avid reader they make it
available I enjoy it you're a fine fine
officer I will make sure this gets into
the evidence Locker
thank you cool no need for you to check
up on it and you know just I'm supposed
to be his sidekick no no you know I'm
your client Conan aren't I your class
I'm just gonna have to leave won't meet
please thank me and your oven and make
me Clark